One Jump Street and created the
characters and with my friend Michael
McCall and I started working on that
when I was 23 and then we shot it when I
think I was 27 maybe 20 26. it was
amazing because we we were trying to
find who was going to play the other
person Channing Tatum at that time was
like known for like romantic movies and
stuff my pitch to him because no one
wanted to do it look women really like
you but guys think you're like a dancer
or like a romance person I think if you
do this movie you'll become like this
giant movie star because everyone will
will be a fan of yours because he was so
funny when I met him I love being around
people I I care about and think are
talented so we're both producers on the
film and I'm one of the writers of the
film and it just gives me joy to see the
scenes change and come to life in new
and interesting ways we can make each
other laugh every day we know we're
Landing in the right ballpark of the
movie and it ended up being this great
partnership friendship he's someone who
I uh really like love and respect